one of the storylines that's still kind
of being written about Republicans in
the 21st century is whether or not
Donald Trump's election in 2016
represents the beginning of a major
multi-decade downfall for the Republican
Party in the United States or not and we
don't know the answer yet the 2020
election is going to be a big part of it
but we already have some data points we
already had Democrats taking over
control of the house back in 2018 in the
midterms by one of the larger margins in
recent midterms anecdotally because they
ran you know the serial sex assault or
Roy Moore in Alabama Democrats took a
Senate seat in Alabama although it's
likely that they're going to give that
back in the 2020 election but then at
the state level there have been some
pretty major advancements and last night
there were a bunch of statewide
elections and Republicans got absolutely
crushed in some key places and it could
be I mean we don't know but it could be
a sign about what could happen in 2020
if we're ready to work but it always
assumes that we're ready to work so
let's go through some of these Kentucky
Kentucky's a very red state a Donald
Trump won by 30 points over Hillary
Clinton in 2016 in Kentucky Kentucky had
a Trump loving governor named Matt Bevin
a major Democratic Party victory has
taken place in Kentucky the Democratic
challenger Andy Beshear who was is I
guess for a little bit longer the
Attorney General of the state knocking
out the Republican governor this is
Kentucky this is not a blue or a purple
state it was a tiny margin just about
5,000 votes that's under 0.5% of the
vote but this is just a brutal loss not
just for Kentucky Republicans but also
for Trump because of what this race
represents now the immediate question
after these results came in last night
was if the Republican Kentucky governor
lost then maybe Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell Republican senator from
Kentucky could also lose in Kentucky in
2020 it's hard to say it's a very
different race McConnell is not as
unpopular as Bevin had become over the
last few months although McConnell's
particularly popular and there is
actually more of a history in Kentucky
if you go back of having Democratic
governors and there is not a similar a
likewise history of having Democratic
senators so we'll see either way
McConnell is going to have to run a
campaign right he's gonna have to run a
real race against Amy McGrath who's
challenging him he's not going to be
able to just ignore the threat from her
that's a great race to work on by the
way if you live in Kentucky or even if
you don't eventually I'm sure there will
be phone banking opportunities so that's
Kentucky
let's go from Kentucky to Virginia in
Virginia Democrats have taken over
control of both the Virginia State House
and the Virginia State Senate they now
are going to control the entire state
legislature they already have a
Democratic governor and Virginia is
looking more and more like a blue state
Democrats have been out of power for 20
years in the Virginia House of Delegates
and they swept yesterday's election so
in Virginia Democratic governor Ralph
Northam Democratic House and Democratic
Senate incoming and Virginia has been a
sort of it's interesting what's happened
in Virginia it's kind of sad actually
they've been held back at the state
level from adopting a lot of the
policies that other solidly blue states
have adopted that could now change with
Democrats taking over total control in
Virginia so that's a very good sign for
Democrats here's another one
Democrats have taken over control of
Mike Pence's hometown for the first time
in almost four decades now it's true
Columbus Indiana which most of you have
never heard of it's not a huge player on
the national political stage I I agree
with you but in terms of the trumpet
element to this Mike Pence is Donald
Trump's vice president his hometown has
voted for Democrats to take over control
of the City Council electing for
Democrats to the City Council Council
taking control for the first time there
in 38 years even when you look at some
of the races that Democrats lost last
night it still doesn't look good for
Republicans and I'll give you a really
interesting example out of Minnesota
which is the governor's race there when
you look at the results out of
out of Mississippi not Minnesota when
you look at the Mississippi results from
yesterday you see that the Republican
incumbent lieutenant governor Tate
Reeves won defeating the Democratic
challenger Jim hood okay it's
Mississippi and a Republican won but
what does this really tell us well what
it tells us says this is one of the
reddest states in the country
Trump won it by 17 points in 2016 over
Hillary in the 2015 gubernatorial
election in Mississippi the Republican
won by 34 points and last night the
Republican only won by 6
turnout was up more than 70 percent
overall but Republican turnout was down
by 6 percent in this race that is
terrible news for Republicans heading
into 2020 and later on in the show we're
going to get into some of the
battleground states how much does
national polling matter we're gonna
start getting into the internals of a
lot of this stuff but if you want I mean
listen the Kentucky result from last
night is great The Virginian results
from last night are great but if you
want to see a drastic change from years
past and a major major red flag for
Republicans it's that Mississippi one of
the reddest states in the country which
they often win in the gubernatorial
races by more than 30 points they only
won by 6 with voter turnout
disproportionately up not from
Republicans but from Democrats and from
independents terrible news from
Republicans heading into 2020 we'll talk
about 2020 a little bit more if I missed
obviously didn't get to everything that
happened yesterday but if there are
races that you think are important
lenses through which we should be
looking to 2020 that I didn't talk about
today get in touch and I will continue
to cover the results on tomorrow's
program